now the Smoke Clears all tears Spilled  Out on the event ground blood and cell  phones ringing intent to tear us down  lose our way and drown take away our  peas bury hope deep underground but no  not here fool you don't have the tools  to deconstruct us unnamed demon killed  many but inspired more scars made but  love saved scars made but hope saved  near misses and lost kisses scattered in  the hot wind of Vegas as those who  escaped such evil lived a talent shout  it scream it alive alive we are alive we  will live for those you left behind  killed from the tower but didn't kill  hope nope carry on and do no wrong you  just can't kill love we are still Vegas  strong